jetzt möchte ich ein komiker in die
deutschschweizer debatte ein
ach was ist die schweiz doch reich an
mythen
der rütlischwur willén tel
oder mariano vor 500 jahren als die
urschweizer mit expansionsgelüste gegen
süden zogen
der papst hat gesagt hilfe hilfe und
schweizer geniessen aber gesagt wir sind
dabei mit bis hin zu wenig könnten wir
nach hilfe fragen und dann sich holender
in primisweiler traum
vorne war milano zu annektieren es kam
zur sogenannten schlacht der giganten
eidgenossen gegen franzosen im september
1515 in marignane südlich von milan
zurück in die schweiz gekommen
die andere gesagt habe verrückt also ist
dick und nach zwei tage die sie fertig
sie französischer kanonen siegten über
schweizer hellebarden ein debakel mit
10.000 toten
die eidgenossen kämpften von nun an in
fremden landen nur noch gegen entgelt
als söldner besiegelt erstmals im
friedensvertrag mit frankreich
mariano ist eigentlich von eagle
formation die die schweizer hatten zum
sich ein igel und dann sind wir zu hause
geblieben und wir haben gesagt teil
bliebe ich spaß so anscheinend fing die
neutralität an
doch wie war es wirklich schweizer
heldengeschichten und was dahinter
steckt ein buch des basler historiker
thomas maissen räumt nun mit den schönen
blüten auf und provoziert die
nationalkonservative rechte unter
christoph blocher das perfekte
wahlkampfthema jetzt kreuzen sich die
kontrahenten rhetorisch die klingen
sie rennen ic gewusst sich auch zu 840
quellen die dem sozusagen die schlacht
der giganten reloaded 90 mariano ist
windig und jäger 1600 heiligt wurzel
wurde neutralität der viel wurzeln aber
eine wurden der mutter ist mit der wende
von mariano zu wild wenn im staate im 17
jahrhundert theorie mit venedig mit
markgrafschaft baden mit der holländer
vertrags macht soldaten dort an schickt
wird wo ich stehe doch neutralität bitte
ich dass ihre fortschrittliche politik
sich die debatte mit blick weit in die
vergangenheit ein deutschschweizer
sonderfall
in der westschweiz jedenfalls weckt
marignane kaum erinnerungen und wenig
emotionen nach een jung mariano gibt's
das ich kann nicht mehr dazu sagen
ich habe nicht die geringste idee ich
bin aus dem wallis tut mir leid dabei
sich nichts eine schlacht sonst noch
fragen
auch der renommierte westschweizer
publizist taktile mokiert sich über die
aufregung zur historie in der
deutschschweiz sein kanton die waadt tat
erst drei jahrhunderte nach mariano der
eidgenossenschaft bei
die schweiz hat eine mythologische bühne
jetzt aber auf diese bühne haben wir
eine zweite rolle für einen ganz
einfachen grund wir waren nicht dabei
es gab ein paar waadtländer in marienloh
aber in den puppen von francois promi
die willensnation schweiz keine 200
jahre alt vertieft vielleicht erst mit
general guisan im zweiten weltkrieg
so ist denn in der romandie mit den
alten mythen kein staat zu machen
wogegen in der deutschschweiz mit
schwerem geschütz gestritten wird sie
natürlich recht ich mir auch gleich
erschoss mit dem rötlichen teil auch
mühte sich ja ab das ist gar nicht so
geschichte erzählt dass ich schweizer
malerei mythen sind von großer bedeutung
für das land wieder kann doch nicht der
grund lag sie für politik gestaltet
der streit ist also letztlich ein
politischer und der gebürtige italiener
rocky vielleicht der einzige der die
schweizer geschichte diskussionslos nach
seinem geschmack erzählen darf
wie wäre es gewesen wenn wir gewonnen
hätten dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich
ein größerer kanton kein test ihm
lombardei wurde der schweiz gehören fc
basel gegen inter milano oder milan
cloning konnte so ein pauschalsteuer
abkommen gefragt aber sicher ist etwas
expo 2015 wurde lombardei der schweiz
gehöre werde schon seit einem jahr
fertig auch das selbstverständlich nur
ein mythos so wie all die anderen von
denen hier die rede war
meist halten sie sich aber hartnäckig da
kann noch so mancher historiker das
gegenteil beweisen
nicola beer die deutschschweizer
streiten sich heftig um sie in der bahn